[SPEAKER_01]: Paul Royero waking up the next day after he went to the large market to buy his clay, refocusing his efforts on creating a homoculi spy with some good clay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, you wake up next morning around 9am.
[SPEAKER_01]: The servants inform you that a man has been delivered.
[SPEAKER_01]: A young man.
[SPEAKER_01]: To the dungeon at your request.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Obviously they were checking with you to make sure that that was correct.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_00]: He got a crossbow, hole right in his chest.
[SPEAKER_00]: Here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, that's my guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: To be treated well, sir?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, just leave him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Shall we tend to his wounds?
[SPEAKER_00]: Make sure he's alive.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're a little creeped out.
[SPEAKER_00]: With my mask, probably.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I can imagine.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you're still wearing the metal mask?
[SPEAKER_00]: I assume I am, probably.
[SPEAKER_00]: You didn't sleep with it, I'm sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, I didn't.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe I should get like a palace mask that's less intimidating.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have a palace mask, but actually you're liking this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I do like it.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's more comfortable.
[SPEAKER_01]: The metal is lighter and it's easier to breathe in.
[SPEAKER_01]: The leather mask is hotter and actually rubs against your skin.
[SPEAKER_01]: For some reason, this is much better made.
[SPEAKER_01]: You get your cistern and refill it with clean water.
[SPEAKER_01]: Drop of your blood into the mix.
[SPEAKER_01]: Taking out your, how much of the clay do you want to have?
[SPEAKER_00]: Enough to make a small one.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, I got 30 pounds worth, so I'm not.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you grab a piece of this place.
[SPEAKER_01]: I take whatever it is I need.
[SPEAKER_01]: And roll, make a, make a lizard animal roll.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it'll be waterproof too, so that'll be nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you begin to shape your homoculi.
[SPEAKER_01]: Four hours go by as you begin to create this critter.
[SPEAKER_01]: Again, roll.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is the clay good?
[SPEAKER_00]: The clay will give you a plus two.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's plus five, your arcanum, which is plus three, plus two is plus five to whatever you roll.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So if you roll a ten,
[SPEAKER_01]: You make a homoculi with zero hit points.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you want to make one with at least one hit point.
[SPEAKER_00]: If I roll a 20, would it be 25, so 10 hit points?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: 16.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: 16 plus 5 is 21.
[SPEAKER_01]: Six hit points.
[SPEAKER_01]: Which makes a six hit point homoculi.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: You create a little creature very similar to a lizard.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then take the Hearthstone and put it on its chest.
[SPEAKER_01]: Taking the Fallujah in front of you, you say the magic words again, lapis the Glossophorum, and the creature twitches and begins to move.
[SPEAKER_01]: You focus your mind into the Mind Stone, correct?
Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: To like tell it to walk forward or something.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you want to say for it to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: Take two steps forward.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your mind is grasped by this entity.
[SPEAKER_01]: All of a sudden a very strange effect happens.
[SPEAKER_01]: You begin to see from the perspective of the small creature as it comes alive.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do I like hear from it too?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, you don't know because there's nothing to hear.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you look as you take your first couple of steps as a lizard forward.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, I'm gonna walk or crawl out the door.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I like change my color to fit in with my story?
[SPEAKER_00]: Like is that...
[SPEAKER_00]: The lizard?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, because it said it blends in with its surroundings.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, so the thing is that the homoculi, if you want to make them more powerful, there are variations that you can use on this.
[SPEAKER_00]: That was said in the book.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: But this is the most simple kind of homoculi you can do, because it's so small and so on.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is your basic start-a-kit homoculi.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm going to...
[SPEAKER_00]: Walk out the door under the crack of it if it can fit.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you basically use the Mind Stone to guide the homoculae and it's kind of a weird sensation because half your mind is seen through the eyes of this creature and the other half of your mind is seen through the eyes of yourself.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you realize that when you control the homoculae you have to be very careful about
[SPEAKER_01]: Your surroundings when you do it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I do stuff in mind and do something in mind?
[SPEAKER_01]: You can, but you realize that it will take some time before you become an expert.
[SPEAKER_01]: In other words, be able to control both things and have concentration in both ways.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, it's not like when you're using the homunculi.
[SPEAKER_01]: Everything is gone from you.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's not like your eyes become its eyes or vice versa.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's like driving and texting at the same time.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right now it's that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, I'm going to, can I like crawl up the side of a wall?
[SPEAKER_01]: You make your Immokuli crawl up the side of the wall.
[SPEAKER_01]: It seems to have the ability to do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, it cannot crawl on the top of the ceiling.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, that's fair.
[SPEAKER_01]: But the wall it can grasp, and it can grasp it as if it were a lizard.
[SPEAKER_01]: But it's not like a spider.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, can I...
[SPEAKER_00]: Find two random people having a conversation.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you want your homoculi to go out into the...
[SPEAKER_00]: It could be just in a hall.
[SPEAKER_00]: A hallway.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And sneak along the hallway.
[SPEAKER_01]: On the floor or on the wall?
[SPEAKER_01]: On the wall or whatever sees them.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So... And you want to stay in your room?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: The homoculi actually moves fairly quickly.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the one you created has tiny wings.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: That allow it to fly if you want.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I fly across to the other wall?
[SPEAKER_00]: You can.
[SPEAKER_00]: You can jump from wall to wall.
[SPEAKER_00]: Awesome.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't really want to do that very much in a castle because it would probably attract attention.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: But it's something that the creature can do.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you walk down the hallway out of your area
[SPEAKER_01]: And look into the passages that go to where.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to go to the kitchen?
[SPEAKER_01]: Where do you want to go?
[SPEAKER_00]: I just need to find two people having a conversation.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, out from where your hallway ends, there are two people, two servants, talking.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I just get close?
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I hear them is what I want to know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: You hear it through the homoculae.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's awesome.
[SPEAKER_00]: One of them says...
[SPEAKER_00]: This is one of the guards.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, we brought the man in as requested by Paul last night.
[SPEAKER_01]: The other one says, have you informed Prince John of this yet?
[SPEAKER_01]: The guard says, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you think we should?
[SPEAKER_01]: The other man, who you recognize now to be the main steward, he goes, yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Everything that Paul Riviero does, you must report to Prince John.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's imperative that Prince John knows what his nephew is up to.
[SPEAKER_01]: He left last night, very late.
[SPEAKER_01]: I let Prince John know this, and the Prince was... Well, he told me to leave Paul alone, but to keep him informed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Please be aware of that.
[SPEAKER_01]: The guard says, It will be as you say.
[SPEAKER_01]: I wonder if the man in the dungeon, should I question him?
[SPEAKER_01]: The steward says to the guard, No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Leave that to Paul.
[SPEAKER_01]: Prince John will deal with his nephew.
[SPEAKER_01]: He will talk with his nephew.
[SPEAKER_01]: If he wishes to question Paul about what he's doing, that is fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is not our concern.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just keep me informed what Paul Romero is doing, where he goes, and who he speaks with.
[SPEAKER_01]: If it is within your sight and ability to know, let the other guards know this as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, sir.
[SPEAKER_01]: He bouts and he goes away.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's awesome.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your lizard.
[SPEAKER_01]: Dude, that is awesome.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your homoculi is just sitting there looking at them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Maybe ten feet above this dude.
[SPEAKER_01]: He looks around.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's no way he sees your homoculi.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's get out of there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's just head back.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's awesome.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you have him crawl back to where you are?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, just have him crawl back.
[SPEAKER_00]: He gets in my room, you know, pick him up.
[SPEAKER_00]: Crawls up your leg.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I put him in a pocket or something, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_00]: Crawls into your pocket.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's this big.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe he can get like a little boxer or something.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, that's awesome.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's great.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hope to talk about what we do.
[SPEAKER_00]: For next session, do you want to...
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want to do one more one-off session?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I think that for next session, let me talk to Steve and see where he's at.
[SPEAKER_01]: I might need to do a one-off session with Steve.